Speaker 1: A Trump supporting failed Republican
candidate has been arrested for his involvement
in the shootings that took place at the
homes of multiple elected Democrats.
This is the United States of America in 2023. The
world looks on in horror, the Albuquerque Journal
reports. Failed Republican candidate Arrested
in Shootings targeting Democratic politicians
homes. Albuquerque police yesterday arrested the
man they say is the mastermind behind a recent
string of shootings targeting Democratic lawmakers
homes. The suspect, Solomon Pena, is a Republican
who unsuccessfully ran in November, made repeated
claims the election was rigged and appears to have
attended the January six riots in D.C. Around
3 p.m., APD SWAT team swarmed a condo complex,
executed a search warrant, made announcements
for Pena, who they said may be armed with a
firearm to surrender as drones flew overhead
within an hour. Officers arrested Pena,
who's accused of paying four men to shoot at the
homes of two county commissioners and two state
legislators. Investigators also believe Pena was
present for at least one of those shootings. Pena
ran unsuccessfully in House District 14. Claimed
on social media he should have won. Where have we
heard that before? He also visited three of the
targeted officials homes unannounced in November.
He showed up and said it was a fraud. The
election should not be certified. APD essentially
discovered what we had all feared and what we had
suspected. These shootings were indeed politically
motivated, said Albuquerque Mayor Tim Keller. They
were dangerous acts not only to these individuals,
but fundamentally also to democracy. What a
shocker. Trump supporting Republican thinks
he won an election. He lost and is willing to use
violence against political opponents. Not a shock.
Sadly, just another day in the United States
of America under this authoritarian, wannabe
dictatorial Republican Party that prays at the
altar of Donald Trump. In the back story of this
is interesting and disturbing. In early January,
APD disclosed it was investigating several
shootings targeting Democratic elected officials
homes around the city. They said Bernalillo County
Commissioner Adrian Balboa's Southeast Albuquerque
home had been struck by eight bullets on December
4th, and a week later, on December 11th, more
than 12 bullets hit County Commissioner Debbie
O'Malley's North Valley home. They just show up
and shoot at the homes. Do you understand what's
happening here? Right. On January 3rd, shots
rang out at State Rep Linda Lopez's home in
southwest Albuquerque. Three bullets went through
her daughter's bedroom as the ten year old slept.
After news of the investigation circulated. State
Rep Javier Martinez, current nominee for House
speaker, then Rep for District 11, inspected his
home and noticed it, too, had damage from bullets.
He had heard gunfire outside on December 8th
and believes that's when the shooting occurred.
These people are disgusting and these are the very
people who are the opposite of what they claim to
be, by the way. This is terrorism in my mind. This
is absolutely terrorism, because this is meant to
send a message not only to these individuals whose
homes were shot, but more broadly, when you say,
oh, Democratic legislator homes are being shot.
It is meant to scare people who are Democrats
vote for Democrats would consider running as
Democrats, etc.. This is a form of terrorism.
We must all ask the question how could Hunter
Biden's laptop have prevented this? Sorry. No,
that's that's wrong. I'm I I'm now too sucked into
Hunter Biden's laptop because of Republicans. We
must all ask the question if they claim to be
for law and order, but they do this, are they
really for law and order? If they claim to be for
democracy, but they want candidates who lost to
still get sworn into office, are they really for
democracy and for counting all of the legal votes
and all of those things? The answers, of course,
to all of these questions are, no, they are not.
They claim to be for these things and they
actually are not. It is terrorism. They found
the guy. Let's now hope they really throw the book
at him and prosecute him to the absolute fullest
extent of the law. The signal needs to be sent.
This isn't acceptable. The problem is we have too
many in this country who believe it is acceptable.
When you do polls and we looked at them maybe six
weeks ago and you ask Americans, is it acceptable
to use violence to achieve your political
goals? More people than ever and many more
Republicans than Democrats now say it is indeed.
One of our sponsors is Helix Sleep. I have been
sleeping on a helix mattress at home for years
now. I couldn't be more happy with it. I recommend
it to everybody the other day, even though she's
not allowed in the big bed, I put my baby daughter
on the mattress and even she loved it. Helix Sleep
is the premium mattress brand offering tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep preferences.
Take the Helix Sleep quiz. It asks you about
your body type your sleeping position. Do you
get hot at night? Do you have back pain? And
then Helix will match you with the mattress.
That's perfect for you. Most people don't know
where to begin when shopping for a mattress,
including me. Helix makes it simple and less risky
because, you know you're getting a mattress that
fits your needs. It ships free. You can try it
for 100 nights to see if you like it. And it
comes with a ten or 15 year warranty. Unlike many
mattress companies, all Helix mattresses are made
in the USA by a skilled production team. So
you are supporting good jobs. Helix Sleep is
giving my audience $350 off plus two free pillows.
This is the place to get pillows, you know what I
mean? Go to helix sleep dot com slash Pac-Man and
use code Helix partner. The link is down below.